وان كانت احاديه تاثيرها مهول الزلزال كما
ذكرت اداره الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه
يعادل بقوته 500 قنبله ذريه الحقيقه
العلميه الجيولوجيه تؤكد ان هناك اكثر من
مليون هزه ارضيه تحدث كل عام بقوه اثنين
ريختر توازي هذه الدرجات سته وخمسين كيلو
غراما من المتفجرات نادرا ما يشعر بها
البشر خاصه وان بؤره الزلزال تقع على عمق
كيلومترات تحت الارض كذلك الامر في الدرجه
الثالثه من الزلزال وهي تعادل 2800 كيلو
جرام من المتفجرات وتمثل نبضات خفيفه
بوتيره مئه الف مره في العام الواحد اما
في الزلزال من الدرجه الرابعه على مقياس
ريختر ومعدل حدوثها عشره الاف مره في
السنه على مستوى العالم فان زلزال الواحد
يوازي انفجار 56 الف كيلو جراما من
المتفجرات نعم هنا يبدا الحديث فوق الارض
عن زلزال يشعر بها به من عليها وان بتفاوت
ايضا يبقى المعدل مقبولا بالمناسبه حتى
عند الدرجه الخامسه على مقياس ريختر فهي
درجه يسجلها اكثر من 1500 زلزال سنويا
يوازي كل منها انفجار مليون و800 الف كيلو
جرام من متفجرات التي ان تي طبعا الدرجه
مع اعشارها تحدث فرقا لكن من هذه النقطه
الان تبدا مراحل الخطر الدرجه السادسه هي
قوه قنبله هيروشيما القوات تعادل سته
وخمسين مليون كيلو جرام من المتفجرات
وصلنا الان الى ترجمه ما قالته اداره
الكوارث في محاكاتنا الدرجه السابعه توا
انفجار مليار وثمانمائه مليون كيلو جرام
زلزال تركيا الاول الذي وقع في غازي عنتاب
كان اقرب الى الثمان درجات سته وخمسون
مليارا من المتفجرات هذا ما تعادله قوته
[موسيقى]